he's a guy that is like chris paul down
here
an important part of the union
membership has taken on a lot of things
as rondo
finds the range from deep
[Music]
gordon got it back off and a couple
cracks at it here's rondo
[Applause]
looking fast in spry
[Music]
time out houston right now we fall in
love with the rockets
offense the lakers haven't scored that's
their first basket in the last four plus
men wow
rockets three for 13 from the field
but only down by four
right now kyle kuzma gets on the board
cross court again good ball movement
covington
[Applause]
bad pass cross court intercepted by
rondo
james fakes the pass left-handed
rondo kicks it out moore's wide open
puts it in
four for four from downtown markeith
morris
12 points in three minutes
rondo going to try a three knocks it
down rajon rondo
at the buzzer floor is a good three
[Applause]
you said that since we came same down in
the bubble
and not just the circumstances of
playing down here without fans
off the steel rondo nice play takes it
away from hard and lays it up and in
what i'm talking about rondo picks him
up full court rips him
oh they banged knees or what but he
certainly grabbed it and was
giving it some extra attention mike
d'antoni citing
personal reasons and that's all he would
give on daniel house he did say it was
not coveted related
oh anthony davis on a beautiful set up
from rondo together he just steps up
pj tucker starts to front rondo throws
it up over the top
just a beautiful pass right on the money
right over jeff green
davis with a rebound one of the few
times late in the shot clock that they
haven't gone to double
james harden rondo gets it to go
returns at the end of this first quarter
here shot clock down to three rondo on
the take
with the left hand that's two drives for
buckets already
and now we'll back it off as they get
set
inside lebron james gets it deep and one
for lebron james now got another ball
handler on the floor in rondo so he can
run without the ball
seals up covington catch shot fake some
statistical anomalies going on in this
game
the fact that the rockets are making a
lot of threes there's a nice finish by
rondo
little finger roll at the rim and now
lebron james on the floor
covington still grabbing at his jaw it
looks like
up top for davis the second time tonight
rondo has found him two stars out there
while hardin takes a break
this could be a dangerous time for the
rockets
lakers might have missed a lob there
with davis
going to the basket now he's got it shot
clock at four davis of fleuria moves
rondo got to put one up
and rondo for three big shot for region
rondo
look at that laker bench that coaching
staff on their feet here's lebron gives
it up morris across court rondo
just hit a three and rondo who's got his
third
packers don't have a third guy rajon
rondo is saying
yes we do and it's me and they double
team harden and get a steal
and another rondo buck team
7-6 now it's lebron james
running with the three from the bench
and of course mark keith morris who got
the start here
a good job putting pressure on in the
perimeter and
running them off the three-point line
harden has not made a three yet the two
makes are mclemore
and covington rockets have just got to
stop
this you cannot be fronting third
quarter
rondo banks it in nice shot by rondo
good take to the basket
and all around it contact microphones
i was not aware of that yeah brings the
sounds out there's a lot from rondo to
anthony davis
one game two and a similar fourth
quarter success in game three
and a ten point win to go up 2-1 and
there's another
free path to the basket for mark keith
morris
got to get one up quick gordon shot fake
puts it on the deck
and it's knocked away by caruso up ahead
rondo all the way lebron james
throws it down that was risky here late
in this game
man this was ill-advised
kuzma hesitation now kicks it out good
ball movement here
rondo's been shooting well from three
and does it again knocks it down
into the hands of caruso second chance
opportunity here for la
leave and kcp with a finish line series
he's come back strong
he's been a big factor here for la nice
lead for kcp in the lakers
but to be fair you gonna put that resume
up of lebron james
versus about 25 26 teams and it would
have been the same thing
oh nice leave anthony davis on the
receiving end once again
and the smart pass right there all you
have to do is raise your eyebrows
make eye contact with your point guard
on the bench
this has been a very effective group for
the lakers up top
howard throws it down rondo
set him up beautifully what 11
fast break points make that 13th for the
lakers in here
a little bit of payback throwing it up
jokic is coming off a 13 assist game and
a triple double against the clippers in
game seven
rondo goes right by porter and finishes
with the left hand
two of seven five points we talked about
michael porter junior the thurling score
as anthony the lobs are everywhere reg
well that was special right there and
now rondo forcing that turnover here
goes caruso out of the pack
gives it up rondo bounce pass dave is
patient
rondo turning the corner a little
floater up and over the backboard
okay give him an h
[Applause]
oh man you're right this is some pistol
pete larry bird behind the backboard
come on oh that's beautiful that's
beautiful great camera work right there
and lebron are basically your centers
out on the floor try to take advantage
of any size advantage you may have
up top lebron james set up by rondo
[Applause]
lebron james you mentioned it reg well
he's playing the a d position right now
at the four or the five so rondo says
let me share some of this love with you
well he'll go on the attack poked away
here comes caruso now grant is there and
caruso with a one-handed jam
[Applause]
man they disrupt jokic
out to alex caruso with the finish
the career show as it's called in l.a
these are one of the minutes for alex
caruso
up top rondo finding howard
with the rebound his first minutes on
the floor rondo out there as well
first wave of substitutions lebron james
sits there's kuzma on the layup
and into the hands of caruso here come
the lakers
rondo rondo lays it up and in
and one for rajon rondo
and i think he kind of fooled morris
because morris thought he was going to
go up with the right hand
and when he decided to go up with the
left lakers are on a 10-2 run
denver's lead was 20.
[Applause]
and now a steal by rondo up ahead james
on the
run lebron james and the lakers on a
14-2
run led by their defense here's the lane
a great
defense a big part of it murray guarded
by rondo he swipes him again
rondo's got another steal here's lebron
on the breakout and he
dunks another one bondo defensively here
comes up with the steal and finds who
else
lebron james shot clock down to five
murray working with grant and picked his
pocket did rondo
rondo in transition with porter behind
him and james
trailing throws it down
well didn't we see a lot of this in that
fourth quarter rondo with the steals and
that transition defense
nice little hesitation porter jr goes
for it
clock at five gives it back to rondo
rondo for three
he's got it kitchener shuffle
inside caldwell pulp springs free
to make big runs bes rondo 16 for joking
she's got five boards rondo
fakes the pass james finds morris down
to davis
everybody getting a touch here rondo up
top four
davis too easy four minutes to go
murray all the way on james hangs and
can't finish
excellent defense by lebron rondo
controls it there's
james with the layup running the floor
and is rewarded
howard able to rescue it plenty of time
here for la
rondo left open for three he'll pull it
and he'll hit it
[Applause]
porter on rondo he'll pull a
three-pointer and he rattles one home
he's in a couple of threes
not afraid to go to the basket gives it
up this time millsap
plowing his way in and morris with the
block that looked like he was on the way
down
up top for anthony davis rondo
with the pass kyle kuzma has come on as
is rajon rondo
well this is when james takes his normal
rest
down 13 frank vogel stays with his
normal rotation
espn probability now is 99.8
james goes inside and throws it down
limited defensively limited on the
backboard
but can function offensively rondo nice
feet inside
and the finish for anthony davis who's
now in double figures
tremendous feed the only flaw that you
you can
point to in this game is he's got to
improve defensively
beautiful pass rondo to james count it
and won
rajon rondo with the perfect alley-oop
lakers back up by a dozen
john by the lakers lebron james gets on
the back side
of the zone and rondo delivers the
basketball on point
that's just eye contact and making a
play
rondo was he was terrific in game one
big part of that turnaround when
laker as that championship ring with the
celtics wants one with the lakers butler
drives can't finish
anthony davis presence once again rondo
looking rondo driving
rondo finishing no affects the game
pushes the ball in transition utilizes
the angles that you give him defensively
and gets to his spot and becomes either
a play maker
or in this situation a scorer okay
that's a great move
knickers by one three and a half gone by
second quarter here in game three
alley-oop to davis rajon rondo once
again with a pass from just inside half
court
he starts him up jay crowder with poor
body position he spins out
no ball pressure on rondo
and banks it in and coach one of the
adjustments we see the heat made
from game two that basket went in by
rondo
this is a horse shot rondo gets into the
seam uses the left hand
look how high that goes off i'm not even
going to try that give me an
h it's a horse
something shot
rajon rondo drive to the basket
left-handed off the glass and the lakers
retake the lead
james making plays all of a sudden the
next time down the floor he says help me
rondo
help help me rondo and he does the job
rondo calling for davis
[Applause]
nice feet inside good patience from
rajon rondo in the setup for anthony
davis
davis double team takes a tough shot
won't go bam out of bio skies for the
rebound but stolen by rondo feet inside
to danny green
heads up play from rajon rondo and the
lakers back up by two
catch falling away
they almost tricked you on that one mike
again that looked like it was close to
going in meanwhile caldwell pulled down
the other round
he back up by five under two to play
second quarter rondo
kicks it out to davis davis gets inside
the long stride
and he's in double figures with 10.
butler's only taking 11 threes in these
finals rondo drives and finishes rondo
off the bench with a couple of buckets
rodgers checks back in the game how does
that change things for you in terms of
what you're trying to do out there
especially
well we have coverages in place on how
we want to you know
pushing the other way
rondo drives another scoop lab lays it
up and in 11 points for rondo
off the bench rondo excuse me
playoff rondo that is about to be
championship rondo again
flat out getting it done for lakeland
rondo shot clock down to five rondo gets
across the lane spins inside left-handed
layup
oh rajon rondo putting on a show here in
the first half
to left spin as the shot clock winds
down
over the very agile
bam out of bio that's just a beautiful
finish
caldwell